Hallo liebe Leute, schön euch alle zu sehen.
Live auf YouTube und auf Facebook, habe ich
gehört.
Ihr könnt uns schreiben im Chat und vielleicht
beantworten wir später wieder ein paar Fragen.
Es gibt im Moment noch keine Untertitel, weil
wir live sind, aber morgen wird es für dieses
Video auch Subtitles geben auf Deutsch.
Ja, ich bin Manuel, wie ihr vielleicht wisst
und ich sitze gerade bei mir zu Hause, denn
ich bin ein bisschen angeschlagen noch.
Ich habe eine Erkältung.
Aber wir haben heute wieder zwei rasende Reporter,
nämlich Cari und Janusz.
Die sind unterwegs in Berlin, um euch zu zeigen,
wie es hier im Herbst aussieht.
Und ich würde mal sagen: Cari und Janusz,
wo seid ihr gerade?
Oh, wir hören euch noch gar nicht.
Bin das nur ich, oder…?
Oh Gott, schon wieder technische Probleme.
Das war doch schon beim letzten Mal so.
Ich frage mal kurz Chris, unseren Produktionsleiter.
Kannst du die Beiden hören?
Gebt mir mal ein visuelles Zeichen.
Cari du kannst ja schon mal per Gesten…
okay, Chris hört dich auch nicht.
Vielleicht musst du noch mal neu reinkommen
in den Stream.
Und währenddessen erzähle ich euch, wer
hier so in den Kommentaren ist.
"Hallo aus Ägypten!", schreibt (Name).
Hallo!
Und "Hallöchen!", schreibt Mohammad.
(Name) schreibt: "Wir hören nix."
Ja, das versuchen wir jetzt zu lösen.
"Hallo aus Seoul!"
Hallo, HK!
Ja, irgendwer hat eine Frage.
Eure Fragen könnt ihr einfach in den Chat
schreiben und wir werden versuchen, ein paar
zu beantworten.
"Hallo aus Paris!"
Hallo Lucie!
"Hallo aus Tunesien."
Keiner hört mich.
Ah, da bist du.
Hallo Cari!
Hallo, da bin ich wieder.
Hörst du mich?
Wir hören dich klar und deutlich.
Juhu!
Guck mal, Manuel.
Ich bin heute für dich und für alle anderen
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer an einen ganz
besonderen Ort gefahren.
Warte, jetzt siehst du noch nichts.
Du siehst nur die Schönheit Berlins.
Wir sind über den Dächern der Schrebergärten.
Ja…
Ein Schrebergarten…
Über die wir schon häufiger berichtet haben
im Podcast, dass das etwas sehr Deutsches
ist, so ein Schrebergarten.
Eine Gartenkolonie.
Ja.
Da ist Janusz.
Oh Janusz, du hast uns ein Bier aufgemacht,
das ist aber lieb von dir.
Und jetzt zeige ich dir den Ort, an dem wir
sind.
Wir sind nämlich hier an der Ber… an der
Bornholmer Straße, schon fast die falsche
Straße genannt.
Hier sieht's so aus.
Es ist noch nicht so besonders schön, aber
diese Brücke, die ist sehr historisch in
Deutschland.
Hier ist nämlich am neunten November 1989
als allererstes die Mauer gefallen und hier
gibt es sogar 'ne kleine Ausstellung.
Sollen wir dir die mal zeigen, Manuel?
Sehr gerne.
Ich fahre da häufig mit dem Fahrrad vorbei,
weil - Ja. - ich dort in der Nähe auch lebe
tatsächlich.
Ich verrate nicht genau, wo.
Aber ich fahre häufiger an dieser kleinen
Ausstellung vorbei und freue mich, dass wir
uns die zusammen anschauen.
Okay, ich fahr mal hier, ich lauf mal hier
rum.
So…
Und vielleicht kannst du uns zeigen, wie,
wo genau die Mauer auch verlaufen ist, dass
man das mal sieht.
Ja.
Hier ist 'ne kleine Gedenktafel.
Die Mauer, die ist eigentlich unter uns verlaufen,
diese Brücke war quasi einer von den Punkten,
an denen man reisen konnte zwischen der DDR
und der BRD.
Mhm.
Und hier unten, da ist im Prinzip, hier ist
die Mauer verlaufen.
Hier siehst du zwei Leute, die üben Boxen.
Und heute… was man so macht, ne.
Und heute gibt es hier einen Mauerweg.
Also, das ist ein Radweg, ein Fußgängerweg.
Hier vorne wird's richtig schön grün.
Das kann ich nur empfehlen, um dort mal herzugehen.
Und ja, hier ist die Mauer gewesen damals,
hier sind die Bahngleise und hier über diese
Brücke, da gab es also quasi früher einen
Grenzübergang, so richtig mit Passkontrolle,
Zollkontrolle.
Und an diesem Ort sind damals, am 9.
November '89, ganz viele Menschen zusammengekommen,
als sie im Fernsehen gehört haben, dass die
Grenzen geöffnet werden.
Und die Leute wollten alle rausgehen, aber
damals war das für einige Stunden unklar,
ob man jetzt sofort ausreisen durfte oder
nicht.
Hier gibt es einige schöne große Bilder,
wie die Menschen dann gewartet haben…
Wow!
Ja, diese Bilder sind…
… und wie sie…
… emotional.
Und jetzt werden sie veralbert von Janusz
Hamerski.
- Janusz, geh mal zur Seite!
Genau, hier siehst du so einen Grenzbeamten.
Und da wurde noch diskutiert.
Und hier gibt es so 'ne richtig kleine, schöne
Ausstellung.
Es ist eigentlich kein besonderer Ort.
Wie du siehst, ist es ist eigentlich ein bisschen
dreckig, hier liegen Bierflaschen rum.
Aber es ist…
Ein Scooter steht in der Gegend rum, so wie
überall in Berlin.
Aber es ist wirklich ein historischer und
schöner Ort und ich kann euch einen Film
empfehlen, um diesen Ort kennenzulernen.
Der Film heißt genauso, wie die Straße:
"Bornholmer Straße".
Hier sieht man eine Karte von Berlin und hier
sieht man noch mal die Mauer.
Wir sind jetzt hier.
Wir sind im Norden von Berlin, das ist Berlin,
hier ist die Mauer hergegangen.
Wow!
Ja, Manuel.
Toll!
Und es sieht richtig schön aus.
Also, das Licht ist gerade sehr, sehr schön.
Das ist die goldene Stunde kurz vom Sonnenuntergang.
Und mehrere Leute auf YouTube und Facebook
fragen, ob es sehr kalt ist.
Wie ist, wie ist das Wetter in Berlin?
Es ist wirklich langsam sehr kalt.
Wie du siehst, trage ich eine Mütze und Handschuhe.
Janusz, was sagst du?
Wie ist das Wetter heute in Berlin?
Ziemlich kalt.
Ja, jetzt schon.
Ja, knallharte Analyse von Janusz.
Es ist ziemlich kalt, aber es ist schön,
ne.
Die Sonne scheint.
Ja schön.
Und… ja.
Man hört Kirchenglocken im Hintergrund bei
euch.
Kirchenglocken im Hintergrund.
Ich, es wird jetzt die Sonne untergehen, deswegen
gehe ich mal über die Straße rüber.
Und hier sieht man noch ein Stück von der
Ausstellung.
Ich kann diesen Film wirklich empfehlen, den
schreiben wir noch mal später in die Kommentare.
"Bornholmer Straße".
Und da sieht man, wie das damals passiert
ist.
Im Prinzip hat dann ein Beamter, ein Grenzbeamter,
der hier quasi der Chef war, an dieser Brücke
in dieser Nacht…
Ja.
Hat dann selbstständig entschieden, die,
ja, die Straße zu öffnen, die Grenze zu
öffnen.
Und damit war offiziell sozusagen die Mauer
gefallen.
Ja.
Und die Bilder gingen dann um die ganze Welt.
Also, hier war damals Osten, dort drüben
war Westen und da standen auch schon Reporter
aus der ganzen Welt.
Und die haben dann direkt berichtet, dass
die Mauer auf ist und Menschen haben das dann,
noch mehr Menschen sind dann gekommen.
Das ist eigentlich verrückt, dass dieser
historische Ort… ich meine, das ist ja wirklich
Weltgeschichte, heute so ein ganz normaler,
so 'ne normale Brücke ist, wo die Autos sich
irgendwie langquetschen, die Leute gehen gestresst
aus der U-Bahn-Station, die ist da noch oben,
der Eingang zur U-Bahn Station.
Und ja…
Ich stehe hier gerade total ungünstig, Manuel.
Die Autos kommen rechts und links, wenn jetzt
hier noch 'ne Tram kommt… Uiuiui.
Ja, bitte passt auf euch auf.
Und während ihr jetzt weitergeht, um uns
vielleicht gleich den Sonnenuntergang auch
zu zeigen,
weise ich noch mal darauf hin, dass ihr uns
Fragen stellen könnt.
Alles, was ihr wissen möchtet über Berlin,
über das Leben in Deutschland, über Cari
und Janusz, das könnt ihr uns in die Kommentare
schreiben oder in den Chat hier bei YouTube
und bei Facebook.
Und wir versuchen, die zu beantworten.
Janusz!
Guck mal, da drüben ist Janusz, ich hab ihn
verloren.
Janusz!
Er läuft mit den zwei Bieren hinter mir her.
Ja.
Ja, ich fange mal, während du auf Janusz
wartest, mit einer besonders wichtigen Frage
an.
Easy German Podcast-Hörer*innen werden wissen,
worum es geht.
Die Frage ist, wie es meiner neuen Spülmaschine
geht.
Die Antwort ist: Sehr gut, ich bin ganz begeistert.
Diese Spülmaschine öffnet sich automatisch,
wenn der Spülgang vorbei ist, damit die Sachen
darin besser trocknen.
Ist das nicht toll?
Das ist der Wahnsinn, Manuel.
Ich finde, wir sollten mal ein Video machen
über deine…
Über Spülmaschinen?
Ja, wie wär's mit einem Super Easy German-Video:
"Manuel erklärt seine Spülmaschine".
Ja, können wir machen.
Vielleicht auch noch ein paar andere Küchenutensilien
und Gegenstände.
Ja, dann wird deine Mütze gelobt.
Ich zeig dir mal Janusz.
Da vorne ist er.
Schöne Mütze.
Meine Mütze wird gelobt?
Die trage ich vor allem, weil ich war heute
beim Friseur und meine Haare sind zu kurz
geworden.
Oh.
Da gibt's viele, die…
Soll ich mal zeigen?
Ja, zeig mal, komm.
Warte ich geb mal…
So schlimm kann es nicht sein.
Ja, doch.
Ja, so schlimm ist es nicht.
Janusz, kannst du mal ganz kurz halten?
Ich muss mal meine Haare im, bei YouTube zeigen.
Und bei Faceebook.
Hallo liebe Leute bei Facebook!
Guck mal.
Zu kurz für meine Haare.
Das ist doch nicht zu kurz, ist doch gut.
Janusz, jetzt mach's doch nicht noch schlimmer
und komm noch näher.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen kurz.
Schnell wieder drauf!
Das finde ich toll, dass du uns das hier so
live zeigst, denn bei Video-Drehs, unser Video-Producer
Chris, der weiß das, da sind wir beide immer
sehr penibel, was unsere Haare betrifft und…
ja.
Sehr eitel.
Sehr eitel, genau.
Das ist ein Wort, das du noch erklären musst,
Manuel.
Naja, Eitelkeit ist keine Tugend.
Es ist, wenn man, wenn einem das Äußere
sehr wichtig ist, wenn man sich immer perfekt
zurecht macht, bevor man sich anderen Leuten
präsentiert, das ist Eitelkeit, ja.
Manuel, ich werde dir jetzt einen wunderschönen
Sonnenuntergangs-Blick zeigen.
Ja.
Die Sonne ist de facto schon untergegangen,
aber es gibt hier einen wunderschönen Blick
über Berlin.
Und noch eine Sekunde, dann haben wir den
perfekten Blick.
Okay.
Und dann drehe ich mich um.
Eine weitere Frage…
Nämlich jetzt.
Oh, wow!
Warte mal, ich muss mal 'nen Screenshot machen
hier oder ein Foto.
Warte mal, ich mach mal ein Foto.
Das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Ja.
Prost!
So Janusz, können wir hier anstoßen?
Mit dem Bier.
Können wir das später als Thumbnail machen,
dieses… ?
Gerne!
Ach schön.
So, Janusz.
Lidia fragt: Was ist der Inhalt heute von
unserem Livestream?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Wir dachten…
Ja!
… wir zeigen euch mal den Sonnenuntergang.
Der Sonnenuntergang, das ist, der ist jetzt
schon vorbei.
Aber ich finde, das ist doch ein guter Ihnhalt,
oder?
Außerdem fährt da die Bahn.
Wunderbarer Inhalt!
Ich finde das nämlich auch so schön an unseren
neuen Livestreams, dass wir wirklich mal ein
bisschen Berlin und andere Städte hoffentlich
auch zu Gesicht bekommen.
Ja.
Ja, was…
Janusz, was sagst du zu diesem Ort?
Es ist sehr romantisch um diese Uhrzeit und
mit dieser Ästhetik hier.
Wunderschön.
Und vor allen Dingen wegen der, wegen dem
Gedanken an die alten Zeiten, als diese Brücke,
auf dieser Brücke wurden die Spione ausgetauscht.
Nee, das ist eine andere Brücke.
Ah, das war…
Da gibt's auch 'nen Film mit Tom Hanks.
Genau, da machen wir unsere nächste Live-Veranstaltung.
Das ist, glaube ich, die Glienicker Brücke.
Die ist aber an einer anderen, an einer anderen
Stelle von Berlin.
Ja.
Aber das ist eine gute Idee.
Wir könnten zu den ganzen Hollywood-Orten
gehen und immer von dort die Livestreams machen.
Richtig.
Es gibt auch mehrere.
Also, es gibt mehrere Filme in Berlin, die
auf Brücken basieren und auf Brücken gedreht
wurden.
Stimmt, ja.
Ja…
Ja.
Wo wollt ihr noch hin jetzt?
Ich schau mal, was noch für Fragen kommen,
aber habt ihr noch, wollt ihr noch weiter
gehen?
Oder bleibt ihr auf dieser schönen Brücke?
Wir könnten hier stehen bleiben, wir können
auch U-Bahn fahren.
Ich dachte, das machen wir jetzt spontan,
vielleicht… oh guck mal, da ist ein Güterzug!
Hm!
Wir können auf's Bahngleis gehen.
Nee bitte nicht.
Wir können auf den Mauer… Nee, nicht auf's
Gleis, sondern an die… Ist das nicht das
gleiche Wort, wenn man da unten steht und
auf den Zug wartet?
Ah, das ist der Bahnsteig.
Achso, ich dachte, das ist auch das Gleis.
Guck mal!
Nee, achso, ja, die Nummer vom Gleis findet
man da.
Ja, also vielleicht müsst ihr uns einen Kommentar
schreiben: Was möchtet ihr, was wir jetzt
machen?
Ja.
Sollen wir in den Zug einsteigen?
Sollen wir in den Schrebergarten gehen?
Auch sehr schön.
Soll Janusz uns zeigen, was er trinkt?
Oder sollen wir auf dieser Brücke stehen
bleiben und gucken?
Also, es gab definitiv schon einige Kommentare
zum Thema Bier, Prost, und auch eine Frage
hier: "Janusz, was ist dein Lieblingsbier?"
Oh, Janusz, eine Frage für dich!
Vielleicht kann er diese wichtige Frage kurz
beantworten.
Ja.
Janusz, Travelling Sapiens möchte wissen:
"Janusz, was ist dein Lieblingsbier?"
Urquell Pils und Beck's, ja.
Pilsener Urquell und Beck's.
Was trinkst du gerade?
Da ich eigentlich nur freitags trinke, trinke
ich heute ein alkoholfreies, zufälliges Bier.
Schmeckt aber gut.
Okay und noch eine Frage für Janusz: "Denkst
du, dass Berlin dein Leben verändert hat?"
Janusz.
Oh.
Nee, dass Berlin sich verändert hat, oder?
Ah, tatsächlich, dass Berlin sich im Laufe
deines Lebens geändert hat.
Janusz, wie fühlst du dich, dass Berlin sich
im Laufe deines Lebens geändert hat?
Ähm…
Warte kurz.
Okay, dazu muss man vielleicht sagen, dass
die Beiden erst seit ein paar Jahren in Berlin
leben.
Seit sieben Jahren.
Aber wir sehen auch schon Veränderung, oder,
Janusz?
Denkst du, dass Berlin sich geändert hat?
Hat es bestimmt, aber ich spüre das nicht.
Wir leben in Berlin erst sieben Jahre und
das ist zu wenig, um solche Vergleiche zu
machen.
Dahingegen, wenn ich jetzt nach Münster fahre…
Komm, wir drehen uns mal um, damit wir nicht
zufällige Leute hier filmen, die gar nicht
auf YouTube wollen.
Nein, dagegen, wenn wir nach Münster fahren,
dann sehe ich ganz viele Veränderungen, ganz
viele andere Geschäfte, ja, die Stadt kommt
mir schon sehr verändert vor.
Hm.
Aber in Berlin bleibt alles beim Alten eigentlich.
(Die) Leute sind hier zu beschäftigt mit
Feiern, als das sie irgendwas ändern wollten.
Weiß nicht, Manuel, was sagst du denn?
Manuel, du hast ja auch schon früher in Berlin
gelebt.
Hat sich die Stadt verändert?
Ja, Berlin verändert sich immer.
Das sieht man auch an den vielen Baustellen,
die es hier immer gibt eigentlich.
Und wenn man diese… Dokumental-Filme…
sagt man das so, Dokumentationen?
Dokumentarfilme.
Danke, wenn man sich die anschaut, dann sieht
man natürlich, dass sich Berlin in den letzten
dreißig Jahren unfassbar verändert hat,
also kaum wiederzuerkennen.
Aber gleichzeitig, ja, die Stadt lebt einfach.
Also so von Tag zu Tag fällt es einem nicht
so auf.
Ja, letzte Frage für Janusz erstmal:
Oh.
"Was zockst du heute Abend?"
Oh, Janusz.
Aleksandar möchte wissen: "Was zockst du
heute Abend?"
Ich gehe am Freitag mit Manuel zum ersten
Mal in einen Proberaum und jetzt zocke ich
nicht so viel, sondern ich suche nach Songs,
die wir dort zusammen spielen könnten.
Und hab 'ne Unmenge interessante Musik runtergeladen
und da muss ich jetzt mich durchstöbern ein
bisschen.
Aber spielst du nicht auch mit deiner Oculus
heute Abend?
Das dachte ich auch, dass es darum geht.
Nee, deswegen.
Ich habe dazu gar keine Zeit.
Ich habe ja heute den ganzen Tag schon gearbeitet
und heute Abend habe ich nur ein bisschen
Zeit, um mich auf diese Probe vorzubereiten.
Okay, das finde ich gut.
Okay, mal schauen.
Also, ich zocke heute Abend, Aleksandar.
Wir spielen nämlich Population One.
Das ist ein…
Ja, ich spiele auch einmal oder zweimal oder
dreimal oder viermal, ja.
Aber mehr nicht.
Das ist unser Lieblingsspiel.
Und gestern haben Janusz und ich zu ersten
Mal zusammen ein Team gehabt und zusammen
gewonnen!
Wow!
Ich gratuliere euch!
Ja und zwar mit Style!
Mit Style?
Ja, mit Style.
Wir haben die Leute so eingekreist und dann
von beiden Seiten angegriffen.
Und war schon Herzklopfen, ja.
Okay.
Ich warte immer noch darauf, dass wir einen
Zuschauer oder eine Zuschauerin finden, die
mit uns spielen möchte.
Ja, ja, ja.
Bitte bitte, dass wäre so toll.
Ihr könnt ja mal eure, nach dem Livestream
eure Kontaktdaten für euer VR-Spiel unten
in die Infobox schreiben, dann…
Ja, oder machen wir so: Wenn ihr zufällig
Population One spielt auf der Oculus, dann
schreibt uns eine E-Mail an: info@easygerman.org.
Sehr wichtig.
Können wir sie dann mit der… ?
Aber nur dann, wenn ihr das schon spielt.
Und können wir sie dann mit der E-mail erreichen
quasi, einladen?
Ja.
Ja?
Oh nice.
Das kriegen wir hin.
Ja, ich habe heute keine Challenges für euch
vorbereitet, aber zum Glück…
Weil wir wollen nämlich…
Ja?
Zum Glück hat unser Publikum das gemacht.
Und zwar schreibt Steven: "Bitte gebt jemandem
auf der Straße ein Kompliment, das ist eure
erste und eventuell einzige Challenge heute."
Wir haben 'ne Challenge von Steven von Steven
bekommen, wir sollen jemanden auf der Straße
ein Kompliment machen.
Oh Gott, das ist… ich nicht!
Janusz sagt: "Ich nicht!"
Ja.
Sind überhaupt besonders viele Leute auf
der Straße?
Okay, machen wir mal, warte…
Du fährst super!
Du fährst super gut!
Guck mal, er hat sich gefreut, der ist mit
den Roller Blades vorbeigefahren.
Ah, wow!
Und der springt, der ist jetzt richtig gesprungen,
seht ihr leider nicht.
Vor Freude hat (ist) er gesprochen.
Vor Freude ist er gesprungen.
Und er hat noch so… uns gezeigt.
Warte, warte.
Schöne Farbe!
Danke!
Na, jetzt hat Janusz… jetzt hat Janusz jemanden
mit, warte, mit dieser Haarfarbe dort komplimentiert.
Und sie hat sich auch richtig gefreut!
Wir sollten eigentlich den ganzen Tag hier
rumstehen und Komplimente erzeugen.
Ja.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Danke Steven.
So, also manche Leute sagen, ihr sollt ruhig
zu den Gärten gehen.
Okay, komm, wir gehen in den Schrebergarten,
Janusz.
Ja.
Wie kriegt man denn das hier wieder weg, diesen
Kommentar?
Das Bier schmeckt super lecker.
Du musst da noch mal draufklicken.
Ja, ich bin schon, ich hab schon weiter-gescrollt.
Naja, dann richte ich euch mal Grüße aus,
aus Mexiko.
Hallo!
Und frage: "Was bedeutet Heimat für euch?"
Das ist eine schwierige Frage.
Das ist interessant, weil mittlerweile merke
ich, also, wir sind ja aus dem Urlaub zurückgekommen,
wir waren in Frankreich und dann sind wir
erst mal nach Münster gefahren.
Und Münster war ja immer lange Zeit meine
Heimat.
Aber ich hab dann gemerkt, ich bin in Münster
nicht mehr zu Hause.
Also, für mich war das Nach-Hause-Kommen
erst in Berlin und deswegen ist jetzt vielleicht…
ja, Münster ist auch meine Heimat, aber Berlin
ist mein Zuhause.
Schwierig, diese Wörter auf Deutsch, ja.
Ja, das geht mir ganz ähnlich.
Also, Heimat ist so ein großer Begriff im
Deutschen vielleicht.
Aber Heimat ist da, wo man sich wirklich zu
Hause fühlt.
Und ich glaube, das ist bei mir mittlerweile
auch Berlin.
Trotzdem gibt es auch noch die Heimat, dort
wo man…
Deutschland ist meine Heimat.
Ja.
Europa ist mein Heimat.
Europa!
Die Welt.
Die Welt ist mein Zuhause.
Genau.
So, wo geht…
Aber Zuhause ist da, wo du wohnst und Heimat
ist ein bisschen mehr, wo du herkommst.
Stimmt.
Oder?
Ja, richtig.
Oder wo man groß geworden ist.
So, jetzt zeigen euch die dreckigen Seiten
von Berlin.
Wir sind jetzt unter der Brücke.
Hier fängt's schon an, Manuel.
Guck dir das hier mal an.
Wie sieht das denn hier aus?
Ja, oh.
Scooter.
Scooter immer.
Aber vielleicht kannst du mal kurz…
Fahrrad auf der Straße.
…erzählen, es waren ja sehr viele Graffitis
gerade zu sehen.
Und das wird häufig gefragt: Wieso gibt es
in Berlin so unglaublich viel Graffiti?
Das soll ich jetzt beantworten?
Ja, bitte.
Ich weiß es nicht, Manuel.
Ich würde sagen, es ist eine internationale
Stadt.
Ist das die Mauer?
Nee, das ist nicht die Mauer, aber hier stand
die Mauer.
Janusz, warum gibt es in Berlin so viel Graffiti?
Die gibt es doch überall.
Aber ich frage mich auch, weil…
Ja, Paris ist, glaube ich, sauberer als …
Ja, München auch.
Wer hat die Energie?
Wer hat die Zeit, um diese… also, manche
sind auch hübsch und oder nicht schlecht,
aber…
München auch.
Hier gibt es einfach mehr Künstler.
Das ist die Antwort.
Ja.
Ja, es gibt eine sehr aktive Graffiti-Szene.
Ich glaube, Leute fühlen sich hier so selbstherrlicher
und selbstständiger und wollen sich äußern.
Sie wollen sich produzieren.
Janusz, ich hab ein Problem, mein Schuhe ist
offen.
Sieht man das?
Aber ich hab keine Hand frei.
In der einen Hand ist die Kamera, in der anderen
Hand ist das Bier.
Ohjeh.
Und dann habe ich jetzt noch den Kopfhörer
drin.
Warte mal, aber jetzt sieht man so nichts.
Soll ich das jetzt… soll ich meine Schuhe
binden?
Bitte.
Warte, aber wir stehen total im Weg hier.
Das ist eine Action?
Das ist mega Action.
Oh, da sieht man einen Lastenrad im Hintergrund.
Da wurde ja auch viel drüber debattiert,
über Lastenräder.
Hier warte, ich muss mal kurz die Kopfhörer
wegmachen.
So geht das hier nicht.
Janusz, du musst dich jetzt selber zeigen,
warte.
Warum soll ich mich selber zeigen?
Damit die Leute was zu gucken haben.
Okay.
So.
Möchtest du eine weitere Frage beantworten?
Gerne, ja.
Die ist genau so schwierig.
Und zwar: "Warum sind die Fruchtsäfte in
Deutschland immer eine Mischung aus zwei Obstsorten?
zum Beispiel Kirsche-Banane, Mango-Maracuja?"
Ja, die Frage ist, die Antwort ist ganz klar.
Die sind es nicht.
Die normalen Säfte, die aus einem Saft bestehen,
die sind sehr populär, waren immer populär.
Aber tatsächlich, es kommt die Mode, Mischungen
zu machen.
Also, es gibt viele Fruchtsäfte-Designer,
die versuchen, immer wieder die, neue Designs
auf dem Markt auszuprobieren, was wir auch
genießen, schmeckt lecker.
Ich glaube, die Mode kommt aus Polen.
Ja wollte ich, ja, ich wollte nicht angeben.
Aber tatsächlich, Polen überrascht mich
gerade da am meisten.
Also, wenn du nach Polen fährst, probiere
all die Säfte und all die Getränke, die
sie dort anbieten.
Es ist einfach unglaublich lecker, ja.
Ja.
Hier wird geboxt.
Zeig mal.
Nee, warte.
Ja, das ist krass.
Warte, du bist zu weit.
- Zeig mal!
Da!
Oh, da.
Aber…
Ja.
Die wollen auch nicht gefilmt werden.
Ja, sonst boxen sie uns noch.
Aber…
So, Manuel!
Ja?
Ja, wo geht's jetzt hin?
Wir gehen jetzt zum Schrebergarten.
Ah, zum Schrebergarten?
Das musste mal erklären, was das ist, für
alle, die unseren Podcast nicht hören.
Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich nicht, woher das
Wort kommt.
Also, das Wort kann ich nicht erklären, aber
das ist ein klein… ein kleiner Garten und
man nennt das auch Kleingarten-Siedlung.
Also, das ist ein Ort, wo ganz viele kleine
Gärten zusammenstehen und man kann sich dann
dort einen Garten mieten und dort dann selber
Obst, Gemüse anpflanzen oder auch einfach
nur ein kleines Häuschen bauen und da nachmittags
sitzen.
Hast du von dem Kirschenweg erzählt?
Hier ist übrigens… Uch, Vorsicht, Janusz!
Hier ist übrigens, hier fängt einer der
schönsten Teile des Mauerwegs an.
Hier gibt es so richtige… Cherry Blossom-Zeit,
weißt du?
Oh.
Ja, stimmt.
Kirschblüte.
Wie in Japan, ja.
Die Japaner haben… gebaut
Also nicht ganz so schön wie in Japan.
- Das ist von einem Japaner gesponsert.
Ja, von der japanischen Botschaft.
Die japanische Botschaft hat diesen Kirschblüten-Weg
gesponsert, sagt Janusz.
Wow!
Gefährliches Halbwissen!
Okay, das ist schön.
Auf dem Weg zum Schrebergarten ein Live-Follow-up
hier.
Ich hab hier im guten alten Duden nachgeschaut.
Und es kommt oder wurde benannt nach dem deutschen
Arzt und Pädagogen D.G.M.
Schreber.
Ah.
Der hat 1808 bis 1861 gelebt.
Vielleicht hatte er den ersten Schrebergarten.
Ah, das könnte sein.
Ja.
Guck mal, es wird dunkler hier, ne.
Wenn wir jetzt in den… und ganz schön flotte
Fahrradfahrer hier unterwegs, du.
Die heizen nur so an einem vorbei.
Ja.
Cari, wir sollen auf diesen Gehweg gehen.
Achse, ich, Janusz sagt, wir sollen vom Weg
runtergehen.
Ach, seid ihr auf dem Fahrradweg gerade?
Also, der asphaltierte Weg.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das hier der Gehweg ist.
Guck mal, hier ist richtig, hier sind wir
schon fast im Wald.
Ja.
Ja, also diese Schrebergärten, die sind so
beliebt, dass man da zum Zeil jahrelang warten
muss, wenn man so ein Platz mieten möchte,
so einen kleinen Bereich, auf dem man dann
seinen Garten pflanzen kann.
Und da gibt es jetzt mehrere Kolonien und
da könnt ihr uns zum Abschluss ja noch mal
zeigen, wie so ein Schrebergarten aussieht.
Ja, da vorne ist gleich ein Tor, da gehe ich
mal rein.
Wenn das überhaupt noch geöffnet ist.
Das ist jetzt natürlich die Frage.
Achso, meinst du, die machen abends zu?
Kann sein.
Oh.
Da kommt wieder ein sehr schneller Fahrradfahrer.
Zeig mal.
Ohne Licht.
Doch, hinten hat er Licht.
Licht an!
Nur hinten!
Janusz möchte gerne wie ein richtiger Deutscher
die Leute korrigieren.
Licht an.
Licht an!
Oh, hier gehts rein, guck mal Manuel!
Okay.
Juan schreibt: "That place is scary."
Das ist aber gar nicht so.
Nee, ist nicht so…
Es wird jetzt nur dunkel, aber es ist ein
total schöner Ort.
Hier geht's rein.
Ja, zeig mal,
Guck mal, da war grad 'ne Maus da unten.
Am Anfang stehen immer so schwarze Bretter
mit ganz vielen Hinweisen für die Menschen,
die dort ihren Schrebergarten haben.
Jetzt darf ich hier nicht so laut sprechen,
damit ich niemanden hier… negativ auffalle.
Nicht, dass wir Ärger kriegen.
Sehr typisch für den Schrebergarten sind
die Deutschlandfahne und so kleine, so Figuren,
die in so einem Garten sind.
Zeig doch mal!
Zum Beispiel hier, warte, kleines Reh, da
hinten seht ihr auch einen Gartenzwerg.
Zeig mal!
Siehst du den?
Er stellt nicht ganz scharf.
Genau, ah, da ganz hinten, da sieht man die,
die, die rote Zipfelmütze.
Richtig.
Es ist sogar ein Schlumpf-Gartenzwerg.
Wow!
Warte, Janusz möchte noch was zeigen.
Hier gibt es sogar oder ein ganzes…
Sieben Zwerge und die…
Schneewittchen und die sieben Zwerge.
Ja, ein bekanntes Märchen.
Oh.
Oh, und guck mal, 'ne kleine Wildschwein-Familie
ist da auch!
Wow!
Also, das ist tatsächlich sehr populär im
Schrebergarten.
Man baut sich 'ne kleine Hütte.
Ja.
Und dann baut man dann noch so… wie nennt
man das?
Dekorationen.
Ja.
Drumherum.
Man macht es gemütlich,
Richtig.
Es gibt aber auch viel… also, je nachdem,
worauf man spezialisiert ist.
Manche Leute sind auf Dekoration spezialisiert,
manche bauen auch einfach Obst an oder Gemüse.
Aber die Häuser sind riesig.
Die Häuser sind schon groß.
Also, das ist jetzt eigentlich ungewöhnlich
für so'n Garten.
Das ist ein neuer Trend.
Aber das is doch verboten.
Ah, das ist… ja.
In den meisten Schrebergärten sind sie viel
kleiner, weil da geht man nur zum Grillen
hin.
Also man darf da auch nicht wohnen dauerhaft,
glaube ich.
Richtig.
Ja.
Normalerweise sind so… das hier sind so
typische Häuser.
Ja.
Wo man eher so kleinere Häuser hat.
Ja, Janusz.
Ja.
Na, das war ja eine schöne Tour.
Will ich auch haben.
Janusz will jetzt auch 'nen Garten haben.
Ja.
Manuel, gibt es denn noch Fragen aus der Community,
die wir noch beantworten können?
Wir haben noch eine ganze Liste an Fragen.
Die können wir aber mal speichern und vielleicht
demnächst im Podcast beantworten.
Ja.
Wie sind unsere Pläne für das nächste Jahr.
Wird es wieder ein Easy German Special geben?
Es ist noch viel zu früh, um über solche
Dinge nachzudenken, ne.
Ich habe heute schon ein…
Was ist denn ein Easy German Special?
Na, wir haben doch ein Silvester Spezial im
Podcast gemacht letztes Jahr.
Ah.
Aber es ist…
Ja, das machen wir.
Ja, machen wir.
Das…
Machen wir Silvester, nee machen wir Podcast
Spezial im Schrebergarten.
Oh ja, das wird kalt.
Das wär doch schön.
Ja.
Schön, ihr Beiden.
Was gibt's noch zu sagen?
Es wird dunkel, Manuel.
Es wird dunkel, wir machen langsam Schluss.
Ja.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr euch rausgewagt habt
heute in die Natur sozusagen in Berlin und
uns ein…
Es hat uns sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Ja, und uns einen historischen Ort gezeigt
habt.
Ja, also, ich kann euch den nur empfehlen,
wenn ihr mal in Berlin seid, kommt mal vorbei
und guckt euch vorher den Film "Bornholmer
Straße" an.
Ja.
Dann fühlt ihr euch wirklich wie an einem
historischen Ort, dann könnt ihr nämlich
verstehen, was dort passiert ist.
Oh, jetzt werdet ihr richtig dunkel.
Da haben wir jetzt richtig den Abend miterlebt.
Ja.
Ja, schön!
Dann bleibt uns wie immer der Hinweis, dass
wir uns sehr freuen würden, wenn ihr uns
auf Patreon als Mitglied unterstützt.
Wenn ihr ein Mitglied von Easy German werdet,
dann bekommt ihr…
Man sieht uns nicht mehr.
Stimmt.
Schnell!
…Materialien zum Deutsch lernen und viele
weitere tolle Dinge und ihr unterstützt Aktionen
wie diese.
Alle Infos findet ihr auf patreon.com/easygerman.
Und ja, wir sehen uns hier wieder auf diesem
Kanal am Sonntagabend.
Sonntagabend und dann kommt tatsächlich auch
ein Thema, was zu tun hat mit der Wiedervereinigung
und dem Zusammenwachsen von Ost- und Westdeutschland
und deswegen kann ich noch mal empfehlen,
vorher sich den Film "Bornholmer Straße"
anzugucken.
Das ist die Hausaufgabe quasi.
Ich hoffe, die Regisseure freuen sich, dass
ich solche Werbung mache für den Film.
Genau, es ist kein Sponsoring, aber passt
thematisch gut für die Episode am Sonntag.
Okay, ihr Beiden, kommt gut nach Hause!
Machen wir!
Janusz, willst du noch mal winken zum Abschied?
Sehr gerne!
Mit den zwei Bierflaschen in der Hand.
Tschüss, ihr Lieben!
Ciao!
Bis bald!